serena williams could advance to the
quarterfinals at Wimbledon today
Williams won her 17th straight singles
match at the All England Club on Friday
today she plays another mom rushes
Evgeniya Rodina Williams who's 36 is
competing for her eighth title bianna
golodryga is here with a million is
difficult comeback ten months after
giving birth beyond a good morning good
news for all moms and athletes like it's
superhero going to a spin class 10
Williams ranking plummeted from the top
player in the world to number 453 after
she went on maternity leave she climbed
back to a ranking of 181 but still has a
long way to go the tennis champ is open
about her struggles as a working mom she
is discussing her challenges and her
challenging pregnancy that left her
bedridden for six weeks and her tough
decision to stop nursing Olympia after
six months this weekend Williams shared
that she missed her daughter's first
steps while training for Wimbledon in
stead of shaming the tennis star for
missing a big milestone moms around the
world rallied around Williams to show
support and empathy six months is really
a long time by the way I didn't nurse
for six months so I mean the fact that
she felt that she did sort of a
disservice as a mother she had to
explain to her infant why she stopped
doing this says a lot about their
connection and also the thing is I miss
Kirby's first steps I was at work
anchoring the noon news so she did her
first steps at noon I got home at 6:00
she still wasn't running so she still is
still walking still that wobbly little
thing so I'm feeling I didn't see it
right in real-time but I still saw it so
I hope she doesn't beat herself up I
hope so and I'm glad mothers are
rallying to her support to say it is ok
you know what you're gonna miss some
stuff and it's okay and the WTA is is
talking about how they're going to
approach some of these rules because a
lot of people say it's unfair that your
ranking is where it was prior to you
having the baby
and yet you
at being you know forced to play against
someone who's had all this time to
practice under watch can't wait for her
to win I know that way thank you